pourquoi est ce que c'est si compliqué
lorsqu'on parle de la rémunération des
médecins au québec
au québec la grande partie des revenus
du médecin provient de la rémunération à
l'acte pour chaque acte médical
il y a un code de facturation en 1970
lorsqu'on a introduit ce système il y
avait 500 codes de facturation
différents et bien entre eux 1977 2014
on est passé de 500 codes à aux mille
code de facturation etc 11000 coop de
facturation peuvent être modifiées
jusqu'à trois fois chacun la régie de
l'assurance maladie du québec gère plus
de 55 millions de factures de médecins
par année ça c'est plus de 220 milles
facture par jour ouvrable la rame peut
investir il ya quelques années
35 millions de dollars dans un système
informatique
juste pour gérer les factures de
médecins le système est tellement
difficile à comprendre que la ram qu à
un centre d'appel pour répondre aux
questions des médecins en 2014 le centre
d'appels de la récup a dû répondre à 63
mille demandes d'information ça ça veut
dire un appel toutes les deux minutes
[Musique]